hay alguna posibilidad en estos momentos
de que la vía diplomática gane terreno
bueno es complicado en estos momentos
aventurar qué es lo que puede pasar pero
efectivamente la situación
es bastante negativa en estos momentos
teniendo en cuenta si entendemos cuál es
la mentalidad de la estrategia rusa que
lo que tiene que lo que ha puesto sobre
la mesa desde el año pasado es un plan
muy premeditado que ha ido dando pasos
poco a poco utilizando la vía
diplomática cuando le ha convenido pero
que en realidad lo que propone lo que ha
propuesto desde un principio es una
reestructuración del sistema de
seguridad europeo y unas líneas rojas
que ha puesto por encima de la mesa
sobre la seguridad de eeuu de la otan y
de europa que son prácticamente
inconcebibles para que las pueda asumir
el mando europeo
bueno ya estamos ante la mayor tensión
en el este de europa desde que inició
este conflicto puntual en tren entre
rusia y occidente con este panorama es
posible realmente que haya un
enfrentamiento a gran escala en el
corazón del continente europeo
bueno no se puede descartar pero tampoco
tenemos tenemos que ser demasiado
alarmistas en este momento porque la vía
diplomática todavía sigue abierta
me reitero con lo que he dicho
anteriormente
ucrania forma parte de la historia desde
el punto de vista de la narrativa rusa y
es muy complicado ahora mismo que rusia
no entiende que ucrania igual que el que
todos los países que han formado parte
del cinturón de la unión soviética y del
imperio ruso son ahora mismo estados
independientes soberanos y que están
sujetos al derecho internacional el
derecho internacional para para rusia
para el presidente putin es posibilista
en el sentido de que solamente sirve en
función de los intereses de su de su
nación
ahora mismo hay un hay una
unión o una fusión entre los intereses
de política interior y política exterior
en rusia y es muy complicado ahora mismo
saber qué es lo que se le pasa por la
cabeza el presidente putin cuando tiene
cuando ha llegado a un extremo y a un
nivel de tensión tan elevado y tiene que
dar cuentas a su propio a su propia
población porque no se puede retirar de
una manera sin poner en riesgo la caída
de su propio régimen por decirlo de
alguna manera
bueno y con lo que está pasando en estos
momentos que tanto se podría decir que
están dispuestos a ceder los líderes
europeos vemos a soles por ejemplo con
el north stream 2 diciendo que aunque el
suministro se va a afectar para alemania
es más importante esta decisión de
frenar la certificación y finlandia
también habla de reevaluar el proyecto
del reactor nuclear ruso rosátom
si efectivamente lo que está ocurriendo
en rusia de alguna manera es es un
eslabón y forma parte de una política
más general de reevaluar el sistema de
seguridad europeo y el sistema de
seguridad que tenía rusia antes de antes
de la descomposición de la unión
soviética quiere volver al sistema de
seguridad de 1991 y en el caso de
ucrania de 1997 y eso es prácticamente
inconcebible para europa europa además
está jugando con la debilidad de los
países europeos que no tienen una
posición común más allá de una serie de
sanciones que tampoco están muy claro
cuáles vayan a apoyar en el caso de
alemania que ha dicho que va a apoyar
el que no el que el
gaseoducto nord stream 2 no pase por
la sanción pues es una buena noticia
veremos en el a nivel interno como
gestiona como gestiona el kremlin esta
situación porque las sanciones
ser duras en la medida en la que europa
se sepa establecer una serie de
sanciones muy correctivas para los
elementos
financieros y políticos del rey y del
régimen pero si son a nivel general para
toda la población no creo que sean muy
efectivas